salut c'est monsieur aujourd'hui
regardez où est ce que je vous emmène
spot de d'un gars c'est la fin des
vacances je rentre demain en métropole
mais mais mais je voulais vous montrer
un truc parce que mon film tout ça que
smartphone
d'ailleurs on utilise beaucoup beaucoup
pour ça c'est à dire faire des photos
des vidéos sur petites bêtes c'est super
cool par contre c'est vrai que c'est pas
souvent utilisés j'ai trouvé une
solution qui est super intéressante pour
pouvoir optimiser complètement vos
photos et vos vidéos et justement
produit vendu
du coup je me suis fait envoyer un petit
paquet ici c'est pas si vous parlez grec
a mis du temps à arriver mais enfin
c'est là alors juste aujourd'hui on va
parler de produits qui viennent de
rideau shield ce n'est pas une vidéo
sponsorisés je tiens à dire mais moins
leur solution est plutôt intéressante
donc on a des coques vous allez voir le
truc est pas mal fichu l'intérêt des
produits inutiles que j'ai là c'est que
vous avez une solution qui est hyper
adaptable en fonction de vos besoins
à savoir que vous avez un grand-angle
lorsque vous voulez film et ça ouvre
davantage pour des parties de blog ça
c'est pas mal vous avez un fisheye vous
savez ça fait un arrondi ça déforme un
peu l'image vous avez un super grand
angle ça ça peut être cool
et puis vous avez ce qu'il faut pour
faire de la macro et un grand-angle
inclut donc ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va tester ça ensemble on va
regarder si c'est intéressant et à mon
avis ça devrait plutôt pas mal
[Musique]
première chose à faire c'est prendre la
coque de rhinau shield la mettre sur
l'iphone voilà il vous faut un petit
adaptateur
tous ces produits vous intéresse je vais
vous en faire gagner donc je vous invite
à nous rejoindre sur instagram
ma chaine hi d'itv monsieur understand
re avait tous les lire en bas et sur
twitter monsieurr tout attaché comme ça
vous allez voir comment le gagner c'est
pas compliqué ça va être super cool
d'ici quelques jours c'est là plater
vous le prenez vous l'installer sur geof
en direct un je n'ai jamais fait avant
c'est pas du tout comment ça marche tout
de suite le 2 que des semences j'ai
compris que c'est beaucoup plus
intelligent que ça ce qu'il faut faire
c'est je pense qu'il faut l'installer à
l'intérieur directement se positionne
comme ça il dépasse un peu comme ça donc
là je pense que j'ai dans le vrai fait
installer mais optique soit en bas soir
au cool on va commencer par tester
qu'est-ce qu'on peut tester en premier
le fisheye là je reste ici puis après je
faire de trois tests un peu ailleurs
histoire voir ce que ça dit puisqu'on
est en crète
on va en profiter pour aller voir un peu
les paysages mais je pense que
franchement c'est la meilleure solution
si vous voulez vraiment optimiser vos
photos et vos vidéos ça fait super cool
on accourt à l'intérieur un petit étui
pour nettoyer annoncer par les suisses
et une pochette pour l'emmener partout
et pas s'embêter là nous aimons fisheye
que je vis
lycée dessus normalement juste pas d'où
est donné 10 loi salique
j'ai un fisheye la laissez moi tant le
test de classe dans cette vidéo fisheye
que vous allez voir apparaître
maintenant comme vous le voyez ça
déforme énormément forcément c'est un
fisheye pourquoi pas pourquoi pas on
continue vous avez aussi et le
grand-angle l'a déjà c'est un peu plus
imposant voyez la taille de la bête
l'âge de films mon appareil je vais
l'enlever pour vous voyez la différence
là c'est sans que c'est impressionnant
ça ouvre vraiment avec de riches
s'enrichissent avec le détail s'en
fichait c'est impressionnant ce système
vaut aussi bien pour la photo pour la
vidéo faire une photo d'abord là par
contre vous avez un grand-angle sans
forcément avoir beaucoup de recul ça
vous évite d'avoir une espèce de faire
ça c'est fait pour l'avoir super loin si
vous voulez faire des blogs ou des
photos hyper large avec mon ami ça c'est
super cool avec le grand angle ça le
fait directement vous êtes 3 je pensais
vraiment tellement super calé j'en ai un
autre qui peut être pas mal à tester je
sais pas vraiment quelle est la
différence entre les deux parce que d'un
côté vous avez ce grand angle et là vous
avez super grand temps de le tester
super grand-angle et on va voir si le
super grand angle est beaucoup plus
super le grand-angle suis vraiment
curieux de voir ce que sa vie je connais
le concept du grand-angle je ne connais
pas le concept du super grand angle
c'est assez impressionnant ça marche
bien mais je préfère l'image de l'autre
du grand-angle alors ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on veut aussi faire des
comparatifs
on va regarder
la différence entre le grand-angle suis
pas content de la macro si vous filmez à
peu près la même chose avec les
différents objectifs comme ça va pouvoir
regarder les images d une à trois heures
pour prendre en compte est maintenant il
doit attester le 2 en un maquereau grand
angle ça du tout ce que ça peut donner
ma couru longtemps d'ensemble ça peut
être plutôt cool
les deux se séparent c'est ça qui est
super cool donc là vous l'utiliser comme
ça vous le mettez sur votre smartphone
vous l'utiliser comme un grand en tout
simplement hyper classique et lorsque
vous venez enlever cette petite partie
devant vous le tibet oups ça va tout va
bien le show et lorsque vous l'utilisez
qu'avec ça ça vous fait de la macro
directement leur part contre et qu'il
m'en faut vraiment vous rapprocher mais
c'est super parce que au final ce que
vous pouvez faire vous prenez votre
iphone ou un smartphone peu importe vous
mettez très près d'un objet vous l'avez
en macro avec vraiment du pain de
détails vous pouvez faire un zoom
numérique dedans et là vous allez
vraiment elle encore plus dans le détail
c'est vraiment un clic est super et en
plus parce que je trouve ça très
intéressant je referme vite avant de
faire une catastrophe supplémentaire
parce que je trouve vraiment top
avec cette solution de cheryl chine
c'est que je vois typiquement la série
fundis vous avez la possibilité de le
mettre sur l'optique du dessus mais
également sorti du dessous ce qui fait
que vous allez pouvoir travailler
différents rendus et je trouve que d'un
point de vue qualité pour pouvoir
vraiment se faire plaisir et pour
pouvoir créer
vous avez un peu tout ce qui vous font
ici donc si on récapitule ce qu'on a
pour faire la vidéo il nous faut
forcément un smartphone compatible
hinault shield ça va être un iphone
iphone cet iphone 8 iphone d'ici là
d'autres produits je vous invite aux
médias leur description comme ça vous
pouvez les voir directement sur le site
de rhinau chine pour voir si votre
smartphone est compatible
oui ou non il vous faut forcément une
coque toujours inutile pour pouvoir le
mettre derrière ensuite l'adaptateur
pour votre smartphone qui est juste là
et ensuite les différentes optique que
j'ai c'est vraiment cool le fisheye de
fish eye je suis un peu moins de fans on
est des gens qui adorent ont cet effet
et moi je m'occupe c'est moi mon truc
le super grand temps où c'est par là je
préfère le grand angle qui je trouve en
tout cas et plus lumineux et plus qu'ali
que le super grand angle et vous avez la
macro grand angle ça pour moi c'est
vraiment super
[Musique]
bon
oh
[Musique]
ce que j'aime le plus moi c'est la macro
en angle et le grand-angle que je trouve
vraiment super parce que lorsque vous
voulez faire des photos des vidéos vous
voulez vraiment améliorer la qualité du
rendu déjà choisir un bon smartphone qui
a une excellente qualité de base et
ensuite avec ces outils là vous allez
vraiment continuer à améliorer la
qualité et ça c'est plutôt cool
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que ça peut vous
intéresser
est-ce que vous avez déjà des produits
green aussi les pièces que vous êtes
satisfait oui non quoi comme enfin de
marquer tout ça et puis bien évidemment
pas continuer à tester tout ça on va en
parler
continuer parce que ils sont super
intéressant on va se poser la question
régulièrement on aura l'occasion comment
améliorer vos photos vos vidéos
personnelles que ce soit pour vous pour
partager sur les réseaux sociaux
ça peut être super cool voilà je vous
laisse profiter encore un peu du la vue
derrière moi je vais chez des tonga sont
pourrissent est insupportable
je vous laisse sur cette jolie petite
vue je retourne très bientôt en
métropole chargé me regardait est-ce
qu'on n'est pas bien on profite on fait
le plein de bonnes énergies à vendre
attaquer la rentrée
et croyez-moi cela rentre il est énorme
parce qu'après un peu un plein de sûreté
ce qui arrive vous avez une fois de plus
à vous connecter sur instagram heidi
tilly monsieur underscore ou re sur
twitter monsieur gros tout attaché comme
ça vous allez croire déjà tenté de
gagner ces jolies optique des coques
valeurs comme cadeau des smartphones à
gagner déjà décidé ça donc on reste
connectés merci a vous d toujours plus
nombreux toujours plus nombreux merci la
mer merci à vous et à très bientôt
j'embrasse ciao